说话人 1: 哈喽，兄弟们，欢迎来到真实社交，我是Jackson
说话人 1: 今天给大家带来一期聊天的案例讲解
说话人 1: 这个妹子当时是在一个地铁口把她拦截下来的，走的非常的急，但是咱们多次拦截，还是把她拦截下来了
说话人 1: 当时我是看到她背面，没有看到她的脸长成什么样，但是
说话人 1: 是她的背面，她的腿非常他们的夸张啊，非常的白，非常的长，也非常的标准，所以说咱们就直接上去检验她的一个真容，结果没有让我失望啊，所以说我就在那里把她给截屏下来，在那里聊天，确定邀约，加微信之类的，废话不多说，咱们进入一个聊天的一个流程
说话人 1: 当时我加
说话人 1: 了她之后，马上跟她打招呼
说话人 1: 兄弟们，加了妹子的微信之后，一定要马上趁热打铁，给她打招呼，不要去拖时间，要把热度赶紧给她延续下来
说话人 1: 她的一个窗口，这里我就用了一个同理心的开场，我说太紧张了吧，没有人在看我们，都以为认识呢
说话人 1: 她当时非常的紧张，她感觉有很多人在看她嘛，或者说
说话人 1: 她可能很少遇到这种情况，所以说会比较慌
说话人 1: 这个时候我们作为男人，就必须要把责任全给扛下来，要在那里把场面给控制住，不要做一个他们的胆小鬼，让女人来承担责任，这种是不行的
说话人 1: 她说没有，我感觉挺多人的，因为很少被别人要微信，她把她的名字发我
说话人 1: 看到这里之后，有些兄弟说，因为她很少被人要微信，所以说她是不是
说话人 1: 那种很好上的女生，那种很好撩的女生
说话人 1: 在这里我给兄弟们说一句啊，肯定不是，这个女的非常的好看，非常的正，而且有两种情况，有一种是女生她故意在装，她说她很少被人要微信，因为她是觉得她属于那种保守型的，不是他们的，她真的很少被人要微信啊，有些
说话人 1: 他以为妹子说了这句话，他就以为他是很高位的一个框架了，不是，兄弟们，这里你还是要做一个试探的
说话人 1: 我在这里给了一个很中规中矩的回答，看她到底是哪种情况
说话人 1: 我说说明你还小，但遇到感兴趣的女生应该主动认识，不是吗
说话人 1: 这里我给了一个给我的行为合理化的一
说话人 1: 一个回答，就是我遇到感兴趣的女生应该主动认识，这是一个很平常、很正常的一个情况，知道吧
说话人 1: 兄弟们，你们要把自己的一个行为合理化，妹子才会觉得你是正常的、有自信的男人，而不是一个一个猥琐的小偷
说话人 1: 咱们接着往下看，这里妹子她同意我的一个说法，因为我刚才不是说男生
说话人 1: 主动认识女生不是很正常吗
说话人 1: 他也说，他说是这样的，他也同意我的一个看法
说话人 1: 他又给自己做一个诗歌，他说，但是我这种类型，我感觉挺普通
说话人 1: 兄弟们也要注意，这种有可能是陷阱啊
说话人 1: 他如果说他普通，你真的跟上的话，你跟他就没得聊了，可能他兴趣马上就下降，不需要
说话人 1: 纠结这个问题不重要，他觉得他普不普通跟我们没有任何关系，只要我们他们的觉得他可以就 OK 了
说话人 1: 这里我直接没理他这个话题，我直接说你更在乎外表还是内在
说话人 1: 其实回答不出我所料， 90% 的女生她肯定更在乎内在，所以说她也回答肯定是内在
说话人 1: 但是她本
说话人 1: 本人得内外皆修，他不仅内在他在乎，外表他也在乎，但是他把东西他说在自己身上，他可能是半个外貌协会
说话人 1: 这里我回了一句，我说我个人偏向外表及格就行了，内在我更在乎
说话人 1: 我不是一个很看脸的人，也不是很看外表的一个人，我更在乎的是一个内在交流的人，而不是跟那些一样，看到好看的他就去舔，看到丑的他就叫别人滚
说话人 1: 我不是那种人，我直接给他阐明了我的一个态度
说话人 1: 兄弟们，不管你是口头上说自己更在乎内在，还是你真的更在乎内在，我都建议你真的多在乎内在的一个东西，千万不要碰到好看
说话人 1: 看的，遇到好看的就去舔，遇到不好看的就叫人家滚，这样千万不行
说话人 1: 不管是好看的还是不好看的，她们都是女人，你只需要一视同仁就好了，不要有任何评判
说话人 1: 你如果成了只会欣赏好看的女生的人，那你就是一个屌丝，你没见过女人，知道吗
说话人 1: 你一定要多注意别人的优点，不要只盯着别人的缺点看
说话人 1: 这个女生她说了一句，她说，但是你加我肯定第一眼是看外表
说话人 1: 这个点很多兄弟可能马上就说，哎呀，不是，我不是看外表，千万不能这么说，我们都会看外表，看外表是接触人的第一步，这个谁都无法避免，只能说我们看了外表之后，还需要更注重里面的一些东
说话人 1: 东西，而不能只是光看外表
说话人 1: 所以说这个问题千万不能死在这个问题上，而且你不能装出来，你真的是那个样子
说话人 1: 意思他撒谎了，他不在那边住，他朋友分手了，他急着去找他，因为他当时跟
说话人 1: 跟我说，他说他回家嘛，我说他住这边，他说对
说话人 1: 他这里跟我解释一下，这个不重要
说话人 1: 我们看这一句，我回答的说，我说不止外表，还有感觉
说话人 1: 我的意思就是，不止外表，还有其他的一些东西我也要观察
说话人 1: 注意这一句，我说你朋友好看吗
说话人 1: 我这句话的意思就是推她一下，让她知道我现在跟她还不是很熟，所以说我会注意她朋友是不是我喜欢的类型
说话人 1: 很多兄弟不敢说这样的话，就怕得罪女生
说话人 1: 但你们现在什么关系都没有，你不需要去做这样的一个动作，你的注意力飘忽一点会更好
说话人 1: 女生会知道你不是一个
说话人 1: 容易上钩的一条鱼，这个很重要，咱们往下面看
说话人 1: 这里他回我，他说我觉得好看，我觉得所有女生都好看
说话人 1: 你知道我当时看到这句话，我第一瞬间反应他是不是一个同性恋，或者说一个双性恋
说话人 1: 因为女生如果说欣赏女生的话，很大概率是往那个方向，所以说我就
说话人 1: 直接问了，我说不会是双性吧
说话人 1: 她可能有容貌焦虑，想去模仿或者说学习其他女生的一些穿搭，或者说什么之类的
说话人 1: 当然那个不重要，我们往后面看
说话人 1: 兄弟们注意，前面已经累积了足够多的窗口，可以看出这个女生对咱们有兴趣的呀
说话人 1: 所以咱们直接做一个邀约，就不跟她废话扯那么多，不要在微信上面聊到高潮
说话人 1: 千万不要这样做，我已经说过很多次了
说话人 1: 这里咱们直接邀约，我说你最近啥时候有时间，咱们出来坐坐
说话人 1: 不出意外，他这里直接回答可以啊，我可能今天晚上可以，刚好下午去拍照
说话人 1: 注意这里，她说我本人不喝酒，是真的不喝酒
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，她不会他们的跟你晚上出来去酒吧，或者说去什么地方，也不会让你去收尾，就是这个意思
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们不要太计科了，这里已经推了你一下，你千万不要再一直买进
说话人 1: 我回答的是，挺好，我也不喝酒，所以说约你喝咖啡
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，第一，我是真的不喝酒，所以说我直接说这个点，我说我不会跟你喝酒
说话人 1: 第二个点，所以说我才约她喝咖啡
说话人 1: 喝咖啡的意思就是，白天，一个咖啡厅，很多人，很安全，很舒
说话人 1: 都是，不会有什么危险，不会有什么不好的事情发生，就是这个意思
说话人 1: 你们也要注意这个点，如果说女生她特别提示你，不跟你去喝酒，那你就得注意一下，不要一直舔一直舔，你要学会适当的放一下，把这个女生
说话人 1: 到这里，她说可以的，到这里基本上就已经确定好了呀，就已经把时间给确定好了，然后
说话人 1: 后他也会出来，地点也确认了，时间也差不多已经确认了，到时候就直接给他发消息就行了
说话人 1: 但是他这里说了一个点，他说去观音桥看外地美女游客，本来我不想跟他瞎扯呀，但是这里我还想给他做一个深度的一个吸引，所以说我这里会回他，我说看有啥意思
说话人 1: 我带你去撩
说话人 1: 这句话的意思是，我可以撩你，我也可以撩其他的妹，你不是那种很唯一的，你不是让我很在乎的那种女生
说话人 1: 我是给他表达这样的一个态度，他说，啊，我不敢
说话人 1: 当然我不知道他明不明白我的意思，我默认他明白
说话人 1: 当然不明白也没事，咱们也不会亏损什么
说话人 1: 我说你站着看
说话人 1: 看我撩就行了，也是在调侃他，他说很尴尬
说话人 1: 这里我们又调侃他，拉近你们之间的一个熟悉度，而不像陌生人，像是一个朋友之间在聊天一样，就很随意
说话人 1: 我说像个娘们一样，这也怕，那也怕
说话人 1: 他就没回了，可能下午在忙着拍照啥的
说话人 1: 到了晚上的点，我就直接拍了拍她
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们可能觉得女生没有回忆了，你需不需要重新去试探，或者说重新去发什么话，心里又很紧张，她会不会出来
说话人 1: 其实不需要，你们之前就已经约定好了，你只需要这个时候你无论发个什么消息，她就会知道你在等她
说话人 1: 所以说我这里直接选择了拍一拍，她说她现在就要来吗
说话人 1: 她想休息一下
说话人 1: 因为她才拍完照回家嘛
说话人 1: 很多兄弟这个时候不要去强势的要求，不要去什么，人家是真的要休息了，她不是敷衍你
说话人 1: 你就让她休息好就行了，因为反正时间也不是很晚，那个时候我也在商场在拍东西啊，所以说我没有很在乎这一个东西
说话人 1: 兄弟们可以看到这里女生跟我解释了很多，她是真的有点累，要休息一下才能过来接
说话人 1: 见我，我就跟他改了一个地点，因为当时我要去其他一个地方，我让他改到那里，他也很OK，他说在哪里，我就给他发定位
说话人 1: 从这里可以看出妹子的窗口非常的大，当然她不是一开始窗口就那么大，是我们之前做了一些操作，真的有进入一些深度的一个沟通，她才会有这么大的窗口，而不是只要你跟她
说话人 1: 说话它窗口就有那么大，不是这个原因，是因为前面我们的操作做对了，所以说它这里反应才那么好
说话人 1: 如果说这里反应不好，肯定不是你现在做错了什么，肯定是你之前有什么东西没有铺垫好，没有做好，才会造成它反应不好的一个情况
说话人 1: 所以说它这里反应好，是咱们之前操作就已经非常 OK 了
说话人 1: 这个是一环扣一环的
说话人 1: 必须得注意，咱们接着往下看
说话人 1: 在上一页，我给他做了一个服从度的测试，我叫他给我发照片，他就给我发了，他照片发给我了，很多兄弟可能会说，哎呀，好看，或者说不好看，或者说什么的，那种没有任何意义，你需要给出你的一个看法出来，超出他意外的一个回答，这样其实
说话人 1: 更好
说话人 1: 当然你普通回答也行，吸引也不会有降多少，但是咱们能做的更好的话，就尽量做到最好
说话人 1: 这里我直接说了一句，我说 p 了多久
说话人 1: 她说 p 了一下肯定，怎么可能不p
说话人 1: 她说她确实 p 了，又合理化她的一个行为，她说怎么可能不p
说话人 1: 我说，浅 P 可以接受，高 P 就下头了，我翻过车，有阴影
说话人 1: 这里咱们还是要表达自己的一个态度，你 P 图可以，不能 P 的太夸张，不能 P 成那种照片
说话人 1: 但是她发的照片其实一点都不过分，而且我都没看出来有 P 的痕迹，就是她本人那样
说话人 1: 但是咱们也要这么说一下子，做一个情绪的一个起伏，做一个推拉
说话人 1: 然后这里她回答，她说她有点高P，这明显她就是
说话人 1: 是开玩笑的，因为根本一点都不p
说话人 1: 我还是保持自己的框架，我说真的呀，我没有
说话人 1: 这个回答就很巧妙，我没有说出自己的一个态度，我就说真的吗
说话人 1: 他说对，又给我发了一个原图
说话人 1: 其实他发的原图跟他 p 的没啥区别，就是尺寸要大一点，反而他们的我觉得是更好看
说话人 1: 这里我说出我自己的一个标准，我说原图正
说话人 1: 好，她 p 的看起来太瘦了不好看
说话人 1: 他说真的吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这里你直接说真的就显得很假，显得是在迎合
说话人 1: 我是真的喜欢那种尺寸大的，所以说咱们的态度在这里，你需要诚实一点，你的话需要更多一点，把这个东西给它具体的形容出来，这样才是一个最好的一个效果
说话人 1: 这里我说可能
说话人 1: 我的审美的话，身材的话，我是偏美式的，接受的尺寸，胸腰臀比的接受的尺寸可能是会比较大一点，就往大了走，就不是喜欢小女生的麻杆身材，筷子腿
说话人 1: 这里我又说了一个，脸的话，我是比较东方的审美，不喜欢欧美脸，很凶的  face，我就比较喜欢小家碧玉，或者说很甜的长相
说话人 1: 这里咱们也给出了自己的一个标准，而不是只要看见好看的就去喜欢，非常重要
说话人 1: 到这里，他说我觉得没有很多人会喜欢我这种身材吧
说话人 1: 其实到这里我才真的知道他是有很严重的一个容貌焦虑，兄弟们千万不要想，他觉得他真的自己很普通，不可
说话人 1: 可能，他长得好不好看
说话人 1: 他的分数高不高
说话人 1: 他身边舔他的多不多
说话人 1: 大家心里要有数
说话人 1: 他觉得自己普通，只是他谦虚也好，假客气也好，什么都好，无所谓
说话人 1: 但你千万不能去跟上，你跟上的话，你就输定了
说话人 1: 他说等一会出门，因为他有点太累了
说话人 1: 我就直接给他定了一个时间，我说 8 点嘛， OK 吗
说话人 1: 因为他那个时候差不多 6: 30，接近7点的样子， 8: 30 确实是很合适的一个时间了，不能太晚，也不能太早了
说话人 1: 因为我突然有事，把地方改了一下，他说OK，咱们就直接跳到最后的一个邀约收尾的一个阶段吧
说话人 1: 在这里发生了一个小插曲，他说不好意思，他可能不能准时到
说话人 1: 好，到这里很多兄弟就慌了呀，就怕这个女生她是不是水掉，或者说她是啥原因
说话人 1: 这里也想框架给她硬一点，我说不知道怎么办
说话人 1: 这里我选择的是一个直接给她定时间，我说 9 点之前
说话人 1: 如果说她会很拒绝这个东西，或者说觉得你框架很硬，很大男子主义，我们再做一个拉回的动作，我们的态度一定要立起来，她说肯定，她说你在里面了吗
说话人 1: 我直接问她，我说你到哪了
说话人 1: 她说在门口，我就直接上去，就是一个完整的一个邀约的一个流程，技术点非常的多呀，大家一定要仔细的学习一下，仔细的体会一下
说话人 1: OK，下期见